there's your opening so
far this season three coaches
fired four general managers gone
and pete i don't know that
the lions intended this to happen the
way that it did we were all paying
attention for the possibility of
bob quinn the gm and matt patricia the
head coach being fired last
friday the day after they were
embarrassed at home by a
not great texans team but it came
saturday afternoon and
nobody really noticed nobody really
seemed to care i think we all kind of
expected it some were surprised that
quinn went too i wasn't because quinn
from the day walked through the door was
going to hire matt patricia it was just
a question of when
it just hasn't worked there but i don't
i mean this lions team has been
as an organization average at best
mediocre most of the time
i don't know how they fix it going
forward but it's clear that what they
were doing wasn't good enough and it was
time to rip the band-aid off
you know mike i think it was uh you know
the saturday afternoon news dump
you know and and at a time when so many
other things were happening
and it was very convenient for the lions
and
look i think as you go forward when
you're detroit
you have to ask yourself what kind of
team do we want
do we think we have a lot of good
elements in place do we want to continue
to kid ourselves
and say that hey we're close we just
need to do x y and z
detroit lions you're not close
you're not close so to me
i think this is an opportunity for the
lions to look at the organization
and to basically ask yourselves do we
want to totally remake this organization
and if we do you know how do we do it
exactly
the first question you have to answer do
you want a general manager first
and if you want a general manager first
i've been told by
uh by someone who's got to do the
picking this year
that the general manager group
is far better than the head coaching
group this year
in terms of candidates you're going to
have a number of really good people to
choose from so
do you want to take that gm and then
start to remake your organization
and then do you want to hire your head
coach do you want that gm to hire your
head coach
personally that's what i would want to
do i don't want anybody inside the
detroit lions organization hiring a head
coach
i just don't want that you know look at
the decisions that have been made
not good so i would hire the gm
let that gm hire the coach the first
order of business then
has to be decide has to be to decide
are we giving matthew stafford another
chance or are we gonna bite the 25
million dollar bullet
in 2021 get rid of them either in trade
or simply a release
probably in trade but are we going to
get rid of them and start over
and mike i'm just left to ask this one
question
you know matt patricia one of the things
that happened
that no one talks about is that
he somehow someway got across purposes
with darius slay so darius slaven had to
be dumped
to philadelphia instead of resign and
then when they have the third pick in
the draft
they had to replace darius slay because
they had no
even close to franchise corners they
take jeff akuda
who's had a very spotty first year
and what did they do they passed on
justin herbert and to otangovaloa
so now what would you rather have on
your roster right now
jeffy coda or one of those two
quarterbacks i know what my answer is
well and what happened with patricia and
slay was very simple patricia was trying
to create that belichick mentality
that idea that there are no sacred cows
that everyone is going to be called out
and he called out darius slay in front
of the team and it upset darius slay
and even though they had an intermediary
try to unruffle slays feathers it never
worked it was that
and even though patricia said i'm going
to be my own guy i'm not going to be
like belichick when you're with him for
15 years you don't realize how much you
are like him and he was running the team
like belichick and it just never went
over well
peter one quick point that i want to
throw back to you as it relates to the
notion that
the lions should hire a gm who then
hires the head coach
who's deciding who to hire the gm though
this is the same group that brought us
matt millen
as the director of football operations
for an extended period of time
somebody's got to know who they're
hiring at gm and that's the first
problem
who's making that decision in detroit
it's a great great question and whether
it's rod wood
or obviously the you know the vestiges
of the ford family
you know with sheila hamp ford uh sheila
fordham
excuse me you know someone has
got to look at this group
of general managers and come down with
that decision
mike it's not an ideal circumstance it
is
simply not but they have to do what the
new york jets have to do
hire a general manager and get out of
the way and i'm not convinced the jets
are going to do that
but they should yeah and
the other aspect of this that we've been
discussing all week and i've mainly been
writing about it at pft
how these team presidents manage to
avoid accountability and continue to be
employed
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports